I've gone through 15 cervical spinal
surgeries 15 yes now let I want to get
this out here because people go
there's no record of her ever getting in
a crash landing and I was on tour my
first world tour big tour the biggest
tour uh touring act and I was at the
height height of outselling a lot of
artists and I was leaving from St Louis
going to Denver in a seven-seater jet
private jet
and 30 minutes 35 minutes into the air I
had just gone to the bathroom and
climbed over luggage to get back to my
seat never got to my seat one of the
engines blew up in the right wing caught
on fire and we plummeted it and I hit
the top of my head on the plane and I
was knocked out
um
people say she's making this up you know
what these young reporters
don't realize
while I was on tour there was no
computer there were no Paparazzi it was
tabloid reporting
and after watching the horrific
spinal cord injuries that Gloria Stefan
went through a car crash for me I did my
whole career by myself I didn't have
anyone I could go to and say what was it
like for you because I started at 17
working with the most
genius ego maniacal like ego maniacal
genius uh I helped win Academy Awards
for these directors and producers Tony
Awards Emmys I worked with the cream of
the crop from time I was 17 years old
and and all of a sudden now
I'm in this in this crazy accident when
when I came to the plane was in flames
and there were six other people on the
plane
that experienced this too there's no
reason I would make this up and have to
lose my career at the biggest catalog
selling art you were lying about because
it's because it's not documented in in
there's a private plane and because I
was able to have people sign ndas I
didn't want anyone to know that I might
perhaps be damaged goods I worked really
hard to get the career that I have to go
right to the hospital I was I woke up in
in the hospital I I was God bless Merv
Griffin's crew saw that a private plane
went down that it was mine and they
rescued us and and in in a cornfield and
I just I remember coming to and like my
tour manager was a guy named Marty ham
and I had this incredible manager Bob
Cavallo who was managing prints at the
time and and you know wait a minute you
know the first thing I think of Ryan I
know people are thinking about it
because I I'm a little uh
morbid at times but I I want to know
what you're thinking when you're looking
what you remember as you're going down
your your heart rate your your mind the
thoughts that go through your mind
because most people don't survive every
plane crash at least as far as I know
and that was the only one that didn't
have something so what were you thinking
right before you remember waking up I
don't remember anything do you remember
anything in the plane I I remember
climbing over I remember seeing an
illumination of light
and I saw my hair makeup artist who was
I had my hair makeup artist my tour
manager my tour accountant
um
I'm missing some people here I remember
seeing um my hair makeup guy Daniel a
light just illuminate his face and I I
saw fear of God and I I must have got
hit with my head and I was knocked out
you were surprised you you left well not
when I came I came too and and we were
all holding hands like I'm going wait
it's not our turn to go this is crazy
and we the co-pilot was able to crash
Landis did anybody die nobody died
um some people had stitches from a from
a dash over forehead uh gash on the knee
um but I was the only one that got
spinal cord injury